on tv on radio and on your smartphone
this is talk tv
[Music]
welcome to piers morgan my friends
uncensored with me jeremy kyle now
coming up on tonight's program over two
decades since 9 11 america finally get
their revenge on almanel's wahiri what
happens next though in this never-ending
war on terror our energy bills are
predicted to rise by a ridiculous 83
percent and we trust in sunnah producing
more u-turns than a dvla test center
when will real help for you ever arrive
a nine-year-old girl stabbed in
lincolnshire was joined by a mother who
knows exactly the hell her family are
going through and later we catch up with
comedian bill bailey walking from
cornwall to devon in memory of his great
friend and amazing comedian sean locke
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
good evening my friends now the
assassination over the weekend of
al-qaeda's iman al-swahiri was a stark
reminder that the threat from terrorism
in afghanistan and beyond is not going
away anytime soon this afternoon speaker
of the house nancy pelosi has become the
most senior politician in 25 years to
visit to one a move described tonight by
china as playing with fire now thanks to
russia we already have a war raging in
europe piers his brilliant dispatches
last week showed us that reality but the
question is is ukraine in fact just the
start i dragged these figures out check
this
august was when world war one broke out
it was also in this month that adolf
hitler ordered the invasion of poland
which sparked world war ii into action
american engagement in vietnam and the
first gulf conflict to other wars that
started in august so with events moving
fast in this hot and feverish time of
the year we've been what we had planned
for tonight's show and have instead
created a special war room to explain to
you what on earth all this means
well as i said and just mentioned
yesterday president joe biden confirmed
al qaeda leader ayman al-zwahiri osama
bin laden's number two and a man behind
the deaths of thousands had been killed
via a cia drone strike in kabul
biden commented the military precision
of the operation and managed to prevent
sufficient for civilian casualties
completely we're delighted to be joined
now by major andrew fox a veteran of
three grueling tours of afghanistan and
former british commanding lieutenant
general david leakey gentlemen welcome
um
a day i think that has caused an
enormous number of people quite rightly
to think um let's ask you
firstly david what does the killing of
this top al-qaeda leader mean in terms
of the world in its entirety
well it said clear indication by the us
that they haven't finished the campaign
and this campaign has been running for
uh since 9 11
and the americans haven't given up on it
and as president biden said this is
justice and that the al-qaeda will
understand very clearly and not just
al-qaeda but the wider group will
understand very clearly that uh
they they do not have impunity or
immunity from retaliation and this guy
has been on the wanted list for years
and years
there's been a bounty on him and they
got their man
i think the question that then comes up
is uh what what are the consequences
what are the repercussions
um on the global stage i don't think
we'll see anything yet but i think
america has sent out a very strong
signal that if uh
if uh insurgent groups terrorist groups
continue to take them on
uh then they can expect
to have retaliation
on their own terms
i guess the question bringing in andrew
here is is the vacuum you you you know
you serve three tours in afghanistan um
this evil leader is no more what happens
next i mean the americans withdrew from
afghanistan this guy was taken out in
kabul he was in a safe house there
what do you think is happening on the
ground now in afghanistan andrew the
safe house was being run by saraj akani
who is the interior minister of
afghanistan so what we're really seeing
is a split between two telegram taliban
groups at this point you have the
kandahari faction in the south who are
very you know more keen than northern
taliban to establish links with the west
and maintain at least a semi peaceful
organization however the northern
taliban
they want an isolated country and now
you have a power vacuum it depends who's
going to be taking over is it haqqani or
is it someone from the kandahari group
uh i think kandahari group is in our
better interest
but the the current reigns of power are
with the haqqanis um that credibility is
damaged because alzheimer's he was
staying with the carnies when he was
killed yeah
so you know and here comes next yeah
exactly i mean you know i want to bring
in if i can former assistant secretary
of state for political military affairs
mark kimmett mark welcome live from
america general mark commit um
the other part of this today we've
talked about al qaeda we've talked about
afghanistan nancy pelosi in the last
couple of hours the most senior i think
in 25 years american politician lands in
taiwan no mention of anything from the
from the white house this is stoking
fire i think china described it as as a
a bad decision stoking the flames what
do americans make of what nancy pelosi
has done tonight mark
well i don't think the average american
really
sees this as a significant event
candidly it shouldn't be
we've had congressional delegations
going over to taiwan
for years and years
as the national security advisor said
if china wants to make a big deal out of
it that's up to them it's not a big deal
for us
and if the chinese want to increase
their military activities if they want
to increase the tensions
i'm sure the united states is prepared
to respond mankind
general kim you know um people would say
that that china have been watching what
russia have done in ukraine uh peers
taught last week about this new axis of
evil you know iran china and russia do
you think pelosi's trip and and the
silence from biden do you think the al
qaeda takeout do you think all of this
will stop that access or not
oh i really don't think so uh biden
silence has more to do with the fact
that he got ahead of his headlights by
disagreeing with speaker pelosi's visit
over there so while the
white house may have wanted to
look like they were supportive in fact
they looked like they were working
against nancy pelosi but as to the issue
of this
axis of evil
as the old term used to go between iran
and china and russia
well that's not a group i'd want to join
because there's a lot of incompetence in
that group there's a lot of capability
uh but not a lot of competence in terms
of fighting
a significant
measure of warfare as we've seen in
places such as ukraine of late
i'm bringing it back to david you talk
about you know
people watch this and they hear
read and see what's going on in the
world should
people be sleeping easier in their beds
tonight is the world a safer place
because that man's been taken out does
it create that vacuum we've talked about
terrorism will continue what what are
your thoughts what would you say to
people i i don't think it makes the
world a safer place and i go back to
this axis of evil thing there are lots
of axes of evil
and they all have overlaps
and one of the overlaps between them is
that they want to destabilize the west
yeah and some of the values and
standards and and and jealousies
and
putin shares that with some of these
groups putin used some of the supports
and encourages these groups to
destabilize their the west they're not
part of the same campaign they are not
on axis uh because putin's aims and
objectives are for russia and they're
different from the ones from al-qaeda or
isis
mighty not look at china now in a more
favorable you know be an ally whether we
talk about business or political uh you
know unity in terms of what's happened i
mean somebody sent this in today and i
know what you're gonna say you know
putin
whatever people make of it this this
aggression against a sovereign nation if
the americans can take out this guy on a
balcony i don't even know where the
rocket was launched from
why can't we do that to putin
well
you go back to why was this done in the
first place here is a a a war criminal
an individual guy who uh
and the the judgments on this will all
be about uh the degree of legality and
illegality the degree of proportionality
and justification he's killing thousands
of people in ukraine particularly
particularly in the public media and in
the west uh you can get away with that
and it's partly political it's partly
legal it's partly proportionality ethics
morality all of these things get weighed
up and the senior guys make a judgment
this one is doable we'll get away with
this we'll get away with it legally
politically medially
immediately and so on so it's
justifiable you can't do you can't do
that to putin he's running a country
this guy was actually this guy's is a
nobody
and he he's 25 million dollar bounty and
he said andrew
he was ill yeah he was
and toothless but it sends a message
that's that's the key thing do you worry
just finally
you worked there you did your bit you've
got contacts on the ground in
afghanistan that vacuum let's just
finish with that do you fear that this
will just continue do you fear that this
will enhance the chance for the world to
be at war or not what do you make of it
no i think the taliban uh at the lower
levels are particularly shaken by this
they thought they'd beaten america but
i've seen that from a social media place
today how did they strike us we beat
them um as david said there's a very
clear message that america can still
reach into afghanistan and touch them
should they start to bring up but us not
being there does it make it harder to
police is that what i'm saying basically
the country harder to police uh i mean
it's already pretty lawless frankly i
mean it's it's hard to see how it could
possibly get worse with the taliban in
charge you know these are a
fundamentalist islamist group who rule
with a reign of terror
it's not going to get any easier or
better whilst the taliban are still in
charge um i guess for everybody watching
this tonight whatever your views of it
it's about what happens next it's about
managing it and and trying to make sure
that that you know the world is a safer
place david leakey andrew fox thank you
very much indeed also major general kim
it in america right next on uncensored
bp
get ready for this have posted their
biggest profit in 14 years a whopping
6.9 billion quid that is as your energy
bill goes through the roof and the cost
of living crisis deepens after the break
we'll hear how one food bank is coping
with increased demand and how some are
even preparing to become warm spaces
once winter hits don't go anywhere stay
with us we're coming back in three
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back my friends this is
uncensored with me jeremy carr for the
next five weeks you lucky lucky people
now the word food bank entered everyday
use in the aftermath of the financial
crash in the coalition government's
austerity budget sadly it looks like
this winter could mark the entrance of
warm banks into the english dictionary
the research firm cornwall insight
predicts the energy price cap is on
track to rise this is ridiculous to
615 quid a year from january and with
our next two potential prime ministers
offering seemingly only u-turns and
magic money trees is there really any
serious help reaching households when
it's most needed any time soon johnny
minnow is conservative colonel bob
stewart along with dawn samford from the
nourish community food bank in tunbridge
worlds dawn before we speak to you i
just want to shoot to colonel bob
stewart um
uh colonel bob um yes the british army
uh you were part of but also part of the
british taiwanese uh all-party
parliamentary group along with lord
rogan a quick response from you colonel
bob on tonight's developments nancy
pelosi taiwan al-qaeda
well i'm very pleased that pelosi has
visited taiwan i'd like to see actually
more contact with taiwan i think we
should actually face off china taiwan's
a very very successful democratic nation
and we should encourage it it's absurd
that it's not part of the united nations
that is absurd it's absurd it's not part
of other international organizations
where it's been blocked by um you know
chinese actions
and with regard to the death of
alzheimeri i think um i i'm very pleased
that he's gone because the man actually
is the sort of person that wants to kill
my my family your family this country
and destroy our society so that's my
answer to your two questions right well
that sort of nails it thank you colonel
bob let's move on before we speak to
dawn who runs the nourish community food
bank in tunbridge wells and bob i said
this last night to somebody who gave me
i suspect the answer you're going to
when people in this country wake up okay
this morning to hear that bp has yet
again reported massive profits 6.9
billion for three months more than
triple the amount it made last year
people say to me oh it's a capitalist
society companies have to make profits
last year they made nothing what do you
a conservative mp say right your part
has been in power for 12 years to people
north and south in this country who are
struggling that much they cannot make
the payments for their bills and they
hear about these conglomerates coining
it in what do you say colonel bob
i say we've got to actually look at
these profits because they're immoral
actually they're they're money taken out
of all of us we've actually got to see
how we can actually reduce them and
actually give that back to the people
that actually make them make the
companies have the profits i.e the
people that sounds very socialist but
i'm afraid i'm i'm feeling that way
myself isn't that interesting from a
from a long-standing conservative mp you
say that sounds socious but to anybody
with a heart or a soul whatever your
political persuasion you would say that
that makes sense because i you can't
really over exaggerate can you bob what
this cost of living crisis is doing for
people they are i mean you know people
will say oh we're struggling but they
really are struggling when bills go up
that much and i don't understand forget
the morality i don't understand why the
government is not saying to these
companies we're going to freeze your
profits we're going to cap your prices
and we're going to look after the people
that frankly you're ripping off
i think i think they are i think they're
going to have to have a look at this
very carefully um i think actually some
moves have already been made and i think
we put the energy companies on on notice
that they can't continue to do this they
have got to be able to justify these
profits and and the amount of money that
people who work for them get sometimes
i completely agree let's put some let's
put this perspective on this because
it's all well and good isn't it on talk
tv to just be throwing figures out the
whole time i want to introduce you to
dawn stamford the operations director of
nourish community food bank in tunbridge
world when we first spoke i remember
saying to you dawn a food bank in
tunbridge world that sounds
ridiculous
just explain to colonel bobby probably
knows anyway but the people listening
how bad it is how many more people
you're seeing and the reality of this
cost of living crisis if you can
um
the reality is
that it is hitting everyone um across my
desk today came a family working family
um lady in the house is poorly she's
terminally ill she's been sent home from
hospital
with an electric powered hospital bed
can't afford the electricity to run the
bed so we as a food bank now provide uh
fuel vouchers for our pre-payment
customers to make sure that they don't
get cut off um and to help these people
because there's nowhere else for them to
turn
it's
everything is tough i
mean every time i think i've seen the
worst case come across my desk there
comes another
in bristol uh today we had we learned we
tried to get the mayor bristol was busy
but that the warm banks are going to be
created i mean just just you know this
is 2022 this is the united kingdom
allegedly the fifth most you know
financially secure country in the world
warm banks for people to actually go and
stay warm this winter and that old thing
i mean i guess dawn what i'm saying is
people will go oh homeless people go to
food banks but the reality is your
clientele's going through the roof your
donations are going down and it's bleak
right it's bleak
yeah i'm not getting much sleep i look a
lot grayer than the last time you saw me
jeremy um yeah i mean our running costs
are increased we we are suffering the
same as every other business up and down
the country donations are through the
floor because the people who donate the
cost of living crisis is hitting them
and our clients are up because the cost
of living crisis is hitting them there
isn't one person that it doesn't affect
not one person doesn't matter what end
of the scale you're at um you're
affected by this
colonel bob if i can come back to you
the current story leadership we've
talked about blue on blue attacks
to me
it's too long it's paralyzing government
and both sunac and trust should be
listening to don sanford tonight and
saying what can we do as a government
after 12 years to prevent warm banks in
2022 how do you respond to that
information colonel bob
well i think my answer is that we've got
to do we've got to actually look at the
whole the whole package we've got to
look about look at society completely
because frankly this is absurd i i can't
stand the idea that people in my country
don't have enough to eat we're a rich
country and we should sort this out but
something is wrong in the way we
you know the way the society works we've
got to sort this out so we've got to
actually make sure that those people the
poorest in our society are looked after
properly i mean um please don't think
that it's just a you know a socialist
view of life it's my view too i believe
absolutely strongly that
we as a country must look after those
people that can't look after themselves
and that means we i think we're going to
have to look at the way we order society
and the way we do things because things
aren't working particularly well at the
moment
but but in terms of you know the current
leadership candidates we heard from you
know boris johnson's government was all
about leveling up the reason i've put
dawn on is that's tunbridge wells for
goodness sake what what do either of
those candidates constructively say do
you think colonel bob that will inspire
people to think we can create and i'm
you say it you're not a socialist i
guess i'm not but it's appalling to
think that people will have to go to a
charitable organization to stay warm
this winter
yeah yeah i i agree i mean um but so we
we've got to do something about it
goodness knows i'm no expert on this i'm
not an economist i'm not i'm going
you're honestly
you're honest you know i i'm as honest
as i can be
um but i'm still a politician i've got
to do the very best for everyone but i
actually think
that in our society we've now got to
look very carefully at those people who
um
in the bottom
section of our society who really need
help we need help to get them off that
we need to help to get them so they're
looked after properly i mean it's not
just on food it's also on things like
medical care just very quickly colonel
bob don't think me rude 30 seconds dawn
you're shaking your head what do you
want to say
with all due respect colonel bob these
are not the lowest and the most
vulnerable in our our communities these
are working families 90 of our clients
are working and the families that are
coming across the households they are in
this because they physically cannot work
anymore they cannot do anything
themselves to change their circumstances
they can't increase their hours they you
know there aren't any more hours or they
just physically can't work them yet i'm
gonna i'm gonna have to wrap the screen
with that can i i'm gonna have to rap i
could do this all night colonel bob
stewart you're not a socialist you're an
honest politician i don't think there's
many of them and dawn stanford what you
do and people like you is an absolute
credit thank you for joining us right
next on uncensored last week the uk
rocked by yet another appalling death as
a result of knife crime this time
unbelievably the deceased was just nine
years of age now stabbings are on the
rise but are the victims getting younger
we'll discuss that in detail after the
break we're coming back in three
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
this is talk tv
[Music]
welcome back to unsensitive with me
jeremy kellner with the seemingly
unstoppable torrent of knife crime
showing no sign of abating it's being
all too easy to just tut and sigh and
turn the page when reading of the latest
brutality well the stabbing of
nine-year-old lilia valatita is not so
easy to move on from her shocking death
this week follows twelve-year-old ava
whites at a christmas light on and 14
year old ferez matu's in april last year
now stabbings are going up
but unbelievably the age of the victims
is actually all going down delighted to
be joined now by tracy hansen her son
josh was 21 years of age when he was
stabbed to death in 2015 she now runs a
charity in his memory which raises
awareness of knife crime and helps
organization organizations in tackling
it also joined by former detective peter
blexley former a superintendent of the
met leroy logan gentleman just to take
but tracy i want to start with you um
i said it last night uh
holly dance the mother of archie
battersby when when it's your kid and i
have five
how do you move on from something so
i don't know horrendous ever
the honest answer is you don't move on
you just move forward
and
do the absolute best you can in their
memory
shining the light on them
there's a 10
increase in knife crime year on year you
say the statistics are higher
um what do you want how do we change
this we seem to have spoken about this
for years what what is your answer as
the mother of a victim
that's a very tall question to be honest
with you and i don't think there is one
answer to that question but i would like
to see
a much more uniformed approach
cross-party approach government police
communities
indeed members of the communities
parents schools right across the board
we need to have open conversations
around crime violence victimology
and we shouldn't be scared of those
conversations because education is the
key you actually go into to primary
schools um to to
to advocate how kids should behave
choose your friends
more carefully etc etc um does that help
you in a way with your own grief
um
yes yes it does because it's saving
other lives
and the feedback we get is is positive
when you're when i share josh's story
it's a truth a true story it's not
there's no
impact share it with us josh was a 21
year young
year old boy i say because he was just a
man
and he walked into a bar
and was approached by somebody that he'd
never met before there was no
altercation no argument no fights all
the things that society typically thinks
should follow any kind of form of
violence
and he was approached by somebody who
had a very long history of criminal
activity and was an organized crime
group member and was carrying a knife
and he approached my son and asked him
what his problem was to which josh
replied i didn't have one and then he
was struck
with full force with a stanley knife
and josh suffocated on his own blood at
the scene
um peter blexley former scotland yard
detective we've spoken in the past a lot
about you know this
this i don't know cancer that is knife
crime we've talked about stop and search
we've talked about the worrying trend of
the age dropping we're here from
such a brave mother who's going into
schools what do we need to do when does
the talking stop what how can we change
this i've had the great honor of knowing
tracy for some years and i'm always
humbled just by being in a company and
much of what she says is absolutely
right
excuse me um the talking needs to carry
on and tracy and other brave people in
various charities are reaching out to
community schools and spreading the
message and trying to stop these young
people before they walk out of the door
of their homes going right have i got
the keys have i got my phone
have i got my knife
that's the fundamental thing that needs
to be tackled how do we tackle that what
do we say what do we do do we make the
laws stronger what do we do it's complex
do we need more police yes do we need
stop and search yes and what a thorny
subject that is look how often people
get up in arms over that
well let's just look at it we have got
children killing children sadly so they
do need to be stopped in search but it's
got to be done properly proportionately
and explained well and there's many
other factors era logan mb former uh
police superintendent with the mayor um
stop and search does it work
if it's done properly absolutely if it's
intelligence based um not seen as a
fishing expedition because
when you have a hit rate of one in ten
you've got someone might be carrying a
knife invariably carrying drugs and then
you've got nine
other people are discontent in the way
they've been treated without respect and
dignity and they could be potential uh
sources of information so when it's one
in ten though i read a statistic last
year let's say i could be wrong seventy
thousand stop and search in london and
they found four or five thousand knives
isn't it worth it
well you can carry it you can find as
many nice the issue is how you
target those who are carrying the night
who are going to use it um so a lot of
that you know people don't just carry
knives and don't tell their mates so
it's a question of educating people to
know they are
not grasping on the mates they're
investing in the community yeah he's
safer and stronger and also and as trace
has already said education's the key
i've been running um
a
charity called void youth for 20 odd
years and
we have seen young people who come from
very dysfunctional backgrounds and
feeling devalued and feeling persecuted
and they they've turned it around and to
be more positive young people through
our young leaders for safer cities
programs so it can be done
actually done on a larger scale taking
lyra's point younger you know we're
talking younger victims why are the
victims getting younger is it social
media or is it what is it in your mind i
think there's multiple factors at play
you know and let's not duck the issue
absent parenting people being absent
from school many other thorny issues and
i can hear people being enraged by me
not me but we have to tackle these we
have to be courageous enough to say
these are the issues how do we tackle
them how do we support these young
people to make the most of the ability
that they've got so they can be the best
possible human being they can there's
got to be a line though between support
and with respect your son was 21 years
of age but when you hear of that that
nine-year-old i mean
i i just to me yes parents but but are
we being strict enough are there are the
penalties for knife crime strong enough
are we what do you make of that do you
think we should be stronger legally
to be honest with you i don't think
that's going to make much of a
difference because if you're petrified
and you're carrying a knife because you
are scared
the penalty
outweighs your fear you're not going to
think about that and again if you're an
opportunist or you are a criminal um and
you're looking to raise your profile
again that's only going to feed into
your profile i'm a bad man or i can do
this or you know i'm a girl who's part
of county lines i don't think that's the
answer
i really don't what i think
the answer is is intervention and
prevention and working together in a in
a holistic way we talk about young
children and what do we do with young
children and young adults well what do
we do with the family as a whole it
can't just be the child it's like i
always say to young children and to the
teachers and i speak them if you fell
down and broke all the fingers on your
hand would you go to a e and ask them to
repair one finger no you would not you
want your whole hand repaired it's the
same thing as
being in a home environment some of
these children have older siblings who
are
part of the criminal justice system just
did you take peter's point briefly the
the the parental responsibility we've
talked about intervention and prayer
we've talked about the police i do agree
that parental responsibility has to
shine through but at the same time
parents need to be educated
i support have supported parents that
don't even understand some of the
consequences around that and they're
listening to their young people having
conversations and they're scared
themselves it's a very complex situation
just around the table i think we all
agree it's complex i think it's it's
important for everybody to be revere you
know to be involved in a in a process
that will improve it can we reverse
briefly from all three of you separately
can we reverse the situation the united
kingdom definitely definitely yeah it's
going to take time i think one of the
things we have to really understand is a
pipeline to that form of mindset and
criminality one of them one of the key
things that's been passed there is
exclusions because when you exclude a
child you're now uh
cast them out from their networks they
can keep them um positive and their
alternative provisions it's very patchy
so we've got to reduce that pipeline
into crime and that mindset of using it
this is where police comes in and
working with
um agencies and because you can't
restore the problem you can't stop and
search away the problem you've got to
work in partnership more on the
prevention side the hardest thing about
this job sometimes i could talk about
this for another what comes out is that
everybody has to work together tracy
hanson for sharing the story thank you
peter blexley and of course leroy logan
thank you so much knife crime it's a
horrific thing and it's it's something
that needs to be sorted and as these
three have just said everybody needs to
work together right next an uncensored
action comedian bill bailey is retracing
his steps 100 miles worth in memory of
his friend the late great comedian sean
lock and he will join us live after the
break we're coming right back
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to uncensored with me
jeremy kyle thank you for tuning in now
12 months ago the uk lost one of the
funniest men ever to appear on british
television sean locke made us laugh on
shows like 15 stories high and 8 out of
10 cats and anyone lucky enough to watch
you stand up live knew they were really
in the presence of a comedy genius his
dear friend and fellow comic bill bailey
has just completed his first day of a
100 mile walk in sean's memory the
journey will take bill along the south
west coast which is one of shawn's
favorite routes in order to raise funds
for an amazing amazing organization
macmillan cancer support delighted to be
joined by bill bailey now and uncensored
bill how are the feet after day one my
friend
uh
well i'd be lying to you if i said they
were in 100 uh up shape um that i'm
suffering a little bit they're a bit
sore
but uh
it was quite a tough walk uh this one
it's it's a tough old section of the of
the path but uh we're in all in good
spirits we you know we feel good um a
hundred miles an amazing um tribute to
the late great shaun lok you've raised i
think upwards of sixty thousand pounds
already uh which is tremendous and and
the details are on screen now how far a
day what are you doing 20 miles a day
for five days or 10 miles a day for for
10 days or what what's the plan
yeah it's
uh well the plan is that
we will be walking approximately 14
miles a day
average
um because we're walking 100 miles in
about seven days in seven days so so
it's some days are longer some days are
shorter uh but it averages out yeah
about 14 days which is i mean you know
it is a good hike if it's on the flat
but the terrain around here is is quite
challenging a lot of the path
uh it goes up um and then down there's a
lot of a sense and descent so
it feels a lot longer it's really tough
on the old uh on the carves but um the
views are spectacular it's you know it's
one of the most
stunning sections of the whole so west
coast path so it's uh you know we really
uh we're we're all in good spirits we're
having fun we had a great day today i
know sean's family and several famous
friends johnny lee mack today what would
what would sean make of this initiative
bill
well
the thing is i think
um
i think sean would
would really be quite chuffed with it
all i think he'd
he'd be
you know sean was was someone that never
really you know he was quite private in
many ways
um
you know although he had quite a very
public profile
but and he loved spending time with
friends and family and i think that
aspect of it i think he would really
love because
what this walk has done is brought a lot
of people together
um
you know like you say his his family are
here
uh his you know extended family his
brother is sisters
you know his cousin is you know his wife
anushka and the kids and
and it's turned into a wonderful sort of
um an occasion where we all get together
and everyone is
remembering him and talking about him
and coming up with stories so i think
he'd be really chuffed i think it was
it's the kind of thing he would love i
mean shawn loved walking he loved the
outdoors
shawn and i walked miles and miles
together over the years
and particularly this this section of
the coast which is which is um which is
one of his favorites
now i know you've got upcoming shows at
london's royal opera house as part of
the enroute to normal international tour
do me a favor to finish bill how would
you you're one of the best how good was
he what made shawn lock so good at
comedy
he he had a unique sense of humor uh
sean had a a brilliant mind a brilliant
comic sensibility he had that
unpredictable quality which so many
other comics would turn out to watch you
know he was a real one-off
um i really appreciate you joining us i
think the walk that you're doing to
raise that money for macmillan is
so worthwhile 60 grand details on the
screen bill bailey good luck with the
next six days you'll be all right with
those legs from strictly and thank you
for joining us on piers morgan
uncensored quarter to nine well the only
thing i've managed to change
in the last two days is i thought that
the rather crass title of piers is pack
i thought it was lazy so yesterday we
renamed it jezza's journals and joining
me now on day two this is going to be
hard work so
hold
listen be quiet i haven't even started
socialist author known to like champagne
grace blakely it doesn't work a marxist
moe drinker don't give me that and talk
tv contributor esther crackers or kraiku
is what they call of course how are we
great um they said to me um there's so
many things that we want to talk about
but but what we should start with is
well i'll tell you what we'll leave that
till the end cost a living you heard me
say bp 6.9 billion quid profit in the
last three months three times last year
whilst this country quite literally is
on its backside bill's going through the
roof 3600 quid in january short sharp
answers is it not disgraceful that these
companies are not being forced to give
back some profit this here's my problem
because i do think it's disgraceful and
they're clearly profiting off giving
people a hard time when they're finding
it difficult to live i fundamentally
disagree with the windfall tax in
principle because it's it's the
government saying oh we think you've
made a bit too much money this year so
we're just going to take it back but
what i do think they should be doing is
making these big corporations pay pay
their fair share in the first place yeah
right you shouldn't need a win for tax
if companies like amazon like bp like
these massive companies are actually
paying what they should be paying in the
first place now well we we would be
politically very apart but colonel bob
stewart tory mp said i'm going to sound
socious it is immoral that these
companies are making this money when
people in this country are struggling
right it's immoral it's irrational it
makes absolutely no sense where is all
this money going this all this money is
going into the pockets of legislative
investments well this is the point right
the reason that we've had all these
long-term cuts to corporation tax is
that we were told we'll cut corporation
tax and nice responsible companies will
go out and spend it on investment create
jobs boost wages we've had a decade of
wage stagnation right at least in part
because we've had this long-term attack
on the labor movement people haven't
been able to bargain for higher wages
and what these fossil fuel companies
done they have not invested in what they
said they would do which is
decarbonizing finding alternative
sources of energy instead they've just
raped it in on fossil fuels exacerbating
the climate crisis and also exasperation
jeremy carl's just become a marxist
she's speaking complete senses
along because we've got lots to get
through penny morton it was like that
with liz trust they were slagging each
other off has now come in support of her
out
last night introduced at the the exeter
hosting it was like
somebody said it was the best uh speech
it sounded oscar like she was prepared
she's been angling for a job in the
cabin hasn't she graciously well i mean
this is so unsurprising this is what
politicians do you know they are
machines that are programmed to ensure
their own self-interest to maximize
their own interests and penny morden's
decided that she's going to fall in line
behind this trust because it's very
obvious at this point that liz trust is
going to win it's why our political
system is so broken it's why it took so
long for boris johnson to be ousted
because everyone you know you're gutted
about that are you what about boris
johnson anything yeah absolutely i think
i think he'll be back in two years do
you know what my conspiracy
i think liz trust will serve the team
right this is true i read this today
this trust will serve for two years
she'll make him the ukrainian envoy to
keep him in the spotlight she will end
up not winning the next general election
it'll be a bit of a stage situation
stamina will get with the smp and boris
will ride back in
that would be my hell on earth i agree
with you that they'll probably be um no
overall majority yeah
yeah it's quite clear
i don't know i wouldn't i think
i think rolling back completely the
tory's majority would be quite hard
because it's quite significant
i think it'll be a slight lead i think
it will be a slight lead and the only
reason why i say that is because it's an
excellent opportunity for kirsten to
really be sort of surging boring but but
the label the labour party's in fighting
the conservative party literally don't
have a leader right now and labour is
basically neck and neck with yeah so the
labour party should be out because
you're so right chris they should be out
there there is
so
many things right now that are going on
that the labour party should be out
there talking about saying we are on
your side we are here to protect your
interests
at sam terry on the picket line angela
rainer's boyfriend he didn't like me
saying that the other day but the truth
is they're going to tear themselves
apart politics in this country is is on
the precipice now i was told if i
mentioned this i have to move my chair
back
600 migrants arrived today
we've got to stop him haven't we
yesterday
yeah that's right
he's waiting for
this us the thing i i feel like because
we always thought about the amount of
money that we're spending keeping these
migrants in the hotel and all of that
and i just said if you look at it from
the french perspective they really don't
have much of an incentive to keep the
migrants on french shores for instance
there's a war isn't there that's why
they're coming here because it's a war
oh no france isn't water on that that's
the thing but i think the bigger
argument is actually being able to turn
them back right because it's not just
about keep because once they land on
british shores that's the end you need
to turn them back not just for the sake
of the money for the industry wasn't it
literally just a few weeks ago that we
were having a big existential crisis in
this country because the birth rate is
too low because we can't get workers to
work in the nhs these people this is
actually the big problem that we have in
this country it's that there aren't
enough people this is brexit well i mean
migration has gone down
no way i'm gonna jump i'm gonna jump
straight in i don't think that's right
at all well it is no no i'll tell you
what's wrong is unfortunately we have we
i always thought the benefit system and
the welfare state was the greatest
invention in the modern world i really
passionately believe this i i'm very
happy to pay whatever to help people who
can't help themselves but the fact of
the matter is nowadays in this country
you can go to work you can go to college
you can choose to go on the dole there
are millions
there are people who do not choose to go
to work because the benefit system has
made it as easy for them it's a fact
whether you like it or not they should
be made to do that narrative is
completely unhinged from reality it's
completely it's like over the last 15
years it's become extremely difficult to
go in and claim these about universal
credit there have been people who've
been found in their houses i don't
disagree with that but there are yeah
yeah
they have been team live because they
haven't shown up for a job center
appointment because they've had
there funerals people who choose to be
on the dole because they know that they
might earn 20 quid more to go to work
and you can argue all the day i agree
with what you've said it's crazy that
you could be on the dole and earning
barely more than you would be i agree
but i'm telling you no partly because
you know
the issue is that we are not supporting
the labor movement we're not supporting
workers to go out and bargain for higher
wages but secondly they're always going
to be people in our society who require
help who require support disabled people
because you can't work at the point and
this is you know we should not be but do
you not keep punching down do you not
want the money hear me out then let's
try a different tack the help that we
should genuinely give to the people that
you've just mentioned
we shouldn't be giving it to migrants
should we
well again migrants come over here this
is the classic thing of like migrants
are simultaneously coming over here and
sitting on benefits and also coming over
here and taking all our jobs actually
most people who come over here do tend
to find jobs often in the nhs there's so
many people in our social okay okay
people who are looking after them
all coming off the boat are not working
for the nhs they don't oh they're not
maybe if they're refugees
they're maybe they're not
the language they need to be
we don't know where they're coming from
we don't know their history these people
are p they're p they're being trafficked
by people smugglers this is an industry
but that's not the gross generalization
about the thousands why is it why is it
at any point why is it that any point
that you don't agree with you say is a
gross you know
and i know this because personally i
know someone who made this trip over the
mediterranean one minute ladies i've got
a headache he actually went to italy but
i know people like this there is for
every migrant you see coming off those
boats there are people that have died in
the mediterranean or on the channel
trying to come here and they're
profiting the people that are profiting
off their deaths are people's money this
country about would run into the ground
without migraines migrants let me finish
let me finish what i'm saying 30 seconds
this country would run into the ground
without people who have come over here
risking their lives risking a huge
amount to come here work for our nhs to
support ourselves
chill chill chill the champagne's coming
out let's agree to disagree don't worry
about talking to me here i've got this
don't worry don't worry i'm on it don't
worry just i've got a clock chill what
an honor esther crackers has been taken
on by grace buddy i loved that that was
fantastic thank you so much
for the love
you prefer jesus journalists to pierce
his pack right they're both awful really
stop talking in my ear i'm absolutely
fine on this watch it thank you you be
quiet in my ear i've got it thank you
you two you'll be back next time uh we
are back tomorrow that's it from me
whatever you have to make sure it's
uncensored okay keep it uncensored eight
o'clock tomorrow nights at your place
have a great night
[Music]
what gets too much air time bland
beige
unopinionated dross
i think the british public
wants to be able to be of an opinion
want to be able to be involved that's
the great thing for me about talk to
people we'll be able to get involved i
just think that we misjudge the british
public if we tell them the whole time
what they should be thinking i am sick
and tired of watching television that
tells you what you should be thinking
talks at you rather than with you
this is talk tv news
good evening i'm zora solomon life
support for archie battersby is set to
be switched off at 11 a.m tomorrow
morning the supreme court rejected an
appeal for further treatment but his mum
is submitting another application to
postpone the withdrawal
a man who was found in the grounds of
windsor castle on christmas day
allegedly armed with a crossbow has been
charged with a number of offenses under
the treason act including threats to
kill the queen twenty-year-old jazwan
singh chale will appear at westminster
magistrates court later this month
and rebecca vardy says she feels let
down by the legal system as she spoke
spoken exclusively to talk tv for the
first time since losing the wagga for
christy libel trial you can catch that
interview tomorrow at 7 pm
but that's all for now we'll have more
after the talk
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you